welcome to this video playing smita
weight from the US done let's see a
bank-owned nope so it's a been only I
have quite good results with this only
night 2 g-3 maneuver huh I'll be six am
a bit bit uncommon you really want to
play Bishop a six and the Benoni okay
but castles should be fine so should I
let him take here or should I take
myself hmm not quite clear
so not spending and lots of times from
device
yeah but what are my ideas he m1 ideas
some still to play the standard
breakthrough with f4 and e5 it's um
Dwight died quite normal but then I want
to make sure that is counted place not
coming quickly so let's play a bush
asleep with our form I also could have
played them in a more restrained fashion
with them with f3 for instance okay
ma'am he may be had Nyjah form okay so I
need to closely file with this standard
attacking idea okay this is probably a
good a good response making sure that I
don't get the eform square for for the
Knights okay I could I could take play
Bishop g5 get into get into a pin
another issue here is that might play h
form so let's let's do that get Bishop
age 6 into into the into the mix and
maybe 92 to f4 this could also be a good
a good way to play if you place h4 for
instance night on air form would attack
g6 which is a bit of a weak spot you
know what should you do maybe 95
attending night to see form now this
makes them make some sense who came is
it yeah it's a bit of a problem night
see force it's a problem I could ignore
at all like Bishop age 694 and Queen F
for something that's not necessarily bad
yeah still let's let's prevent this
counter play maybe this is too lame so
possible
can maybe maybe this is not not forceful
enough some ideas bishop age 60 maybe
maybe just take on your phone it's not
ridiculous just getting the palm back
and also there's Bishop g5 it's also a
valid idea yeah okay here i should i can
take you for it's not it's not
necessarily bad so let's not spend too
much h4 is also exposing this pawn
Bishop to g5 and I might just take it so
this still looks like like isn't in some
danger
yeah also possibly just use them use the
weekend scram so I'm getting into this
pin now it's a question what should like
do yeah I can take I can play Knight f4
Jake you should take them at the entity
force hanging but it's not it's not a
winning or something i would write ok
let's get this this night into the
attack if you takes on f4 i think i just
take with the rook maybe he's got nine
h5 I by Bishop takes is also not bad
winning a temple Bishop takes and maybe
he has got III I would have 20 30 cable
that's for once try to keep the time the
time advantage and watch now maybe he's
playing III any way possible like I'm on
Bishop h6 plane III so that I need to
take with the bishop as possible
or to g5g five nothing not sure at home
okay let's let's do that you will play
three at least this looks like the way
to go just getting my bishop back yeah
but I didn't see any em any great move
now now this I just didn't appreciate
that's of course a valid ID em yeah okay
need to take it okay scam bond that so
how to continue that technol taking is
probably not great
I need to get get the Queen involved
protecting the night maybe Knight f6
coming and the queen is eyeing them g6
bond this was the main idea looks very
very weird but true to form that's my
intention yeah it's probably this
probably has some some tactical some
technical drawback very likely it's just
time Morgan check yeah very little time
check check this just discovered check
that's something change I didn't see any
yeah and you win Jack I can even take it
unbelievable check back for fits on tie
one on Tommy yeah no idea so quite quite
a strange game yeah why did I lose the
threat here yeah probably Bishop h6 was
bad this should be at least yeah let's
say unclear or something I had initially
I think white was was an excellent shape
but somehow i lost the threat him maybe
here is this Queen d2 move I don't know
of course this is a complicated position
this could be a good idea attending
intending to check yeah so it's it's
certainly compensation I I just prefer
white a bit this is why I'm maybe Joe
optimistic sometimes to hear I hear the
computer says that this is excellent for
white yeah I had the suspicion that be
three was a bit bit too slow but i
didn't i didn't really didn't really saw
something else didn't really see
something else can she had made still
complicated but probably not
not great light h7s a good move yep yeah
I really lost the thread here ya hear
the simple way to play I played this
probably not great all right computer
thinks it's okay actually yeah but i can
i can play Knight f6 I've call that some
of that but I wasn't sure that this
really helps I mean his King is very
open computer says equal it's possible
something like this is always always it
wrong yeah i mean if black insists hard
to tell yeah very complicated and around
TM whoop dat was very cool move ok yeah
I didn't I wanted to play 95 and use the
King Joe check cover III is probably not
great town looked xt5 was what's good
here Black is great yeah but here we
both had seconds this is really a just a
gamble oh I can check medium-chain
embarrassing oh here check check yeah
this is made check mate check yeah this
is probably also great but didn't didn't
manage to quit see three years yeah okay
it's just eight seconds both both
players interesting am the other benoni
is always very sharp right thanks for
watching